inutile de vous demander si les miracles
existent vraiment lorsque vous découvrez
l'histoire de bahia bakari l'une des 153
personnes à bord du vol yemenia 626
entre la france et les comores et dont
le scénario à vire à la catastrophe le
30 juin 2009 l'appareil effectuait la
dernière partie d'un vol
paris-marseille-sanaa-moroni
il s'est abîmé en mer alors qu'il
préparait son atterrissage en effet
alors que le vol était en phase
d'atterrissage pour les comores celui ci
disparaît des radars pour se crasher en
mer ne laissant que très peu d'espoir
aux secouristes mobilisés une course
contre la montre s'engage et la france y
participe elle a envoyé deux bâtiments
de la marine et un avion militaire avec
6 tonne de matériel et des secouristes
miraculeusement une rescapée sortira
quasi indemne de cette tragédie il
s'agit de bahia bakari 13 ans à l'époque
a accompagné de sa mère qui ne survivra
pas à l'accident elle s'est accrochée à
la vie jusqu'au bout quelques brûlures
une fracture de la clavicule bahia
bakari une adolescente de 13 ans et très
certainement l'unique rescapée du crash
bahia sera retrouvée dans l'eau agrippée
à un débris d'avion pendant près de dix
heures avant d'être secourue
bakari était avec nous ce soir pour nous
raconter comment elle a survécu à cette
tragédie
questions comme comment ça m'a
d'ailleurs ça va ça va on a évidemment
mille questions à vous poser parce que
évidemment autour du autour des crashs
d'avion se pose toujours plein de
questions vous êtes donc l'unique
survivante vous êtes maman qui
malheureusement est décédé en domptant
crash l'unique survivant donc on est
dans l'avion
tout se passe bien a priori
quand ça s'est passé on nous a annoncé
qu'on allait atterrir aux comores donc
comme un tout les atterrissages d'âge on
nous demande d'attacher nos cinq sur une
redresser
il ya aucun signe avant-coureur n'y a
pas une vibration n'y a pas eu un
brouillard into un peu normal je sens
des turbulences mais ça avait l'air de
choquer personne parce que je regarde
autour de moi
donc je me suis dit que peut-être la
zone d'atterrissage de commandes étaient
un peu compliqués qui est s était sujet
à des turbulences à ce moment là mais
rien de bizarre à part ça on est
généralement où on nous conseille de
regarder la tête des hôtesses plus que
s'il est
donc là tout était normal tout était
normal aucun signe qu'il allait se
produire à cet accident donc on a là nom
du commandant de bord on va se poser
tout va bien donc vous vous attachez
votre ceinture et got maman y'a rien du
tout et là il est tout d'un coup ça
bascule dans l'horreur en fait moi j'ai
un trou noir donc je sais pas du tout ce
qui s'est passé entre le moment où je me
suis redresser attaché ma ceinture et le
moment je me retrouve dans l'eau j'ai
aucune image en fait
cet accident jadot donc vous n'avez
aucun souvenir aucun souvenir mais
malgré tout vous vous réveillez donc
dans l'eau oui accrochée à un débris en
fait je vois trois débris devant moi et
à ce moment là je suis parfaitement
logique en me disant que j'ai très peu
de chances de survivre si j'attrape pas
quelque chose pour ma grippe et donc je
prends le plus grand en me disant que je
vais pouvoir monter dessus et sauf ce
que je peux pas donc je reste juste à
gripper pendant ce temps là vous avez
votre gilet de sauvetage non donc ça
veut dire que si on essaie de
reconstituer ce que vous avez vécu ça a
été très soudain on n'a pas le temps d
attention et un problème dans cette
affaire mettez votre idée donc vous
n'avez même pas le gêner non on n'a rien
puisqu'il n'y a eu aucune annonce feront
dire quoi donc c'est dépassé de l'otan
au grand gros de la lumière à l'ombre et
la décompression tu sais d'un coup et
hop ça que vous êtes évanoui peut-être
il ya comme un temps vous restez dans
l'eau et seuls des djs qu'on est on est
on est deux journées de nuit c'est la
nuit à pleurer la nuit alors en plus
d'aller comment il ya des il ya des
requins en plus dans le
[Musique]
cas où vous restez 10 heures seul dans
l'eau vous êtes une petite fille de 12
ans quand même 13
et bas parce que deezer c'est
interminable
oui mais je pense que quand on est une
petite fille
alors en fait quand ça s'est déroulé la
nuit j'étais consciente qu'il y avait un
accident parce que j'entendais aussi des
femmes autour de moi appeler à l'aide
à l'aide aussi comme elle est à force
avec la fatigue etc je me suis endormi
en fait sur mon débris d'avion donc
quand je me réveille le lendemain matin
je suis un peu dans un délire où je me
dis où ton d arriver sauf moi donc je
m'accroche à cette idée là où ma mère
forcément est arrivé et je me dis mais
elle doit être tellement paniquée
puisqu'elle était tellement protectrice
avec ses enfants il faut que je
m'accroche pour pouvoir la retrouver
mais oui vous pensez qu'il y avait
d'autres survivants au moment du crash
et que bucky qui ont disparu pendant la
nuit oui oui avec notre survivance
puisqu'il ya un avion qui a été envoyé
pour les repérer mais mali n'ont pas
changé alors dans la tragédie on l'a dit
vous avez perdu votre maman
malheureusement vous êtes une petite
fille de 13 ans 12-13 ans
comment est ce qu'elle est les
sauveteurs vous la norme il n'y a pas de
cap ballack a pas de survivant vous êtes
la seule dame en est ce que est ce que
vous y penser avant quand vous récupère
non je pense pas alors déjà c'est pas
des vrais sauveteurs qui ont récupéré
ses des pêcheurs
puisque qu'en lan quand la catastrophe
ne s'est déroulé tout le monde a voulu
donner allez à l'aide secourir des
personnes donc c'est des pêcheurs et à
ce moment là j'étais vraiment dans les
vapes donc on ne parlait pas beaucoup et
puis quand je suis arrivée à l'hôpital
on affine examiner c'est là où il ya un
psychologue qui m'a annoncé puisque j'ai
demandé ma mère qui m'a annoncé que
j'étais la seule on a retrouvé jusqu'à
présent
alors juste ou du tout c'était au moment
de l'atterrissage donc vous n'êtes pas
très loin de l'aéroport quand même nom
mais pas comme on pourrait pourquoi vous
restez 10 heures seul dans la lys à
l'incroyable divise ce que vous quand on
atterrit voilà on vous dit vous êtes à
une demi-heure de l'atterrissage
l'avion est facilement repérable on sait
on sait très bien
est-ce que depuis bahia on vous a
expliqué ce qui s'était passé et quelles
étaient les raisons de ce crash une
erreur de pilotage après les conditions
aussi d'atterrissage à s'était paré
il y avait énormément de vent
il ya des manques et des lumières aussi
sur la piste d'atterrissage donc en fait
c'est plusieurs choses c'est souvent un
enchaînement c'est ça oui qu'est-ce que
alors c'est une question bizarre mais ce
qu'on peut se retourner contre la
compagnie aérienne ou ou essayer de
porter plainte je sais pas c'est
vraiment une question bête mais c'est un
gouffre actuellement il ya un procès qui
va avoir lieu l'année prochaine
après mais c'est toujours blonde façon
dans ces affaires là et puis là il y
avait d'autres pays qui étaient
impliqués donc allonge encore les délais
alors on va voir les images de votre
sauvetage et de votre rapatriement en
avion je crois regardez
à bord du jet qui la ramène en france
bahia se réveille doucement
l'adolescente est une miraculée elle n'a
qu'une clavicule cassée et des
écorchures au genou et au visage
je sens
bahia a besoin de soins constants elle a
perdu sa maman dans le crash les
psychologues le lui ont déjà dit mais
pour l'aider à faire face les médecins
veille sur elle en permanence
quand on voit ces images bahia savoure
sa vous replonge dans l'ambiance je veux
souhaiter de tout revoir aujourd'hui à
ce moment là oui je me souviens parce
que j'étais assez intimiste après avoir
foi que j'avais face à moi des caméras
je venais à peine d'atterrir en france
donc je savais pas comment ça allait se
passer pour moi et
voilà donc mais oui je me souviens très
bien de ce moment là après y'a mon père
aussi qui est montée pour rejoindre à
bord de l'avion avant que l'on fasse
descendre
j'avais des très bons médecins aussi à
côté de moi qui étais là pour
m'accompagner tout le monde du voile
donc
j'ai douze autres très émus très émus et
il ya un côté un
héroïque aussi dans le fait que vous
soyez restés dans l'eau pendant 10
heures c'est ça moi qui m'impressionne
dans ces cas là vous avez pensé à quoi
pour tenir vous aviez un but vous parce
que c'est une éternité 10 heures dans
l'eau comment vous avez réussi à tenir à
ce petit objet juste en pensant que ma
mére
pour l relation vraiment très
fusionnelle avec elle et je me disais
que si j'arrive pas elle va pas nous qui
avait dévasté donc je m'accrochais ce
dès la apprécié sur un c'est pas évident
on a envie de lâcher certains moments
mais j'ai compris je voudrais savoir ce
que les psychologues nous ont expliqués
par rapport à cette amnésie donc puisque
vous vous souvenez plus d'un de ce qui
s'est passé de la catastrophe en
elle-même est ce que c'est dû au choc
traumatique est ce que c'est une amnésie
qui peut être temporaire cause qu'est ce
qui vous ont dit les psychologues jamais
vraiment d'explication c'est vrai par
rapport à ça on m'a dit que ça pouvait
arriver dans ce type d'accident mais pas
la raison
et jamais su
quand on est la seule survivante
est-ce qu'il y en a une espèce de forme
de culpabilité enfin c'est à dire
pourquoi pourquoi moi pourquoi je suis
la seule section serait le syndrome sur
lui oui alors oui il ya le syndrome du
survivant mais moi je n'ai pas ressenti
puisque
de par mes croyances je me dis que c'est
le destin ça devait se passer comme ça
et les personnes beaucoup plus forte que
moi qui aurais pu survivre et moi j'ai
eu cette chance après après cet accident
est ce que vous avez repris rapidement
et de vous de votre plein gré l'avion
weeb0 prima 2 mondial a retrouvé
huit je voulais reprendre l'avion j'ai
pas voulu que ses impacts ma vie donc je
reprends l'avion hier pour les gens qui
en garde je pense que déjà il ya plein
de gens qui ont peu retombé en avion
sapin c'est un vrai fort de prendre
l'avion vous vous avez survécu à un
crash terrible parce qu'il est quand
même 220 200 322 steam ou 150 victimes
on pense pas quand on reprend l'avion au
pire on est on arrive à auront des dents
comme ça mais en fait à chaque fois je
me dis qu'il ya très peu de chances que
ça m'arrive a été retenu et bayal et
volant je t'avais dit bon ça
techniquement les chaussures 1 milliards
d'euros déjà de survivre donc maintenant
c'est monsieur je suis à l'abri vous
verrez tout à l'heure on va recevoir à
monsieur ses besoins jusqu'au bout dit
il a crevé galère lui même et qui prône
allemands ils se croisent ils
reprendraient me retourne avec
les blacks pendant dix à quatorze les
soldats les poignées sauter dans les
trous faits par les saumures disant fier
pas d'un hobbit va tomber de france
appelle m alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
baiia comme comment est votre vivent
donc votre maman donnée n'est plus là
votre papa vous avez 17 occuper de vous
à vous êtes vous êtes mariés ont des
enfants vous êtes vous en êtes où
et mes frères et soeurs donc je
travaille j'ai été diplômé il ya un an
j'ai un master en immobilier machado
parce que vous regardez être un soleil
quand on avait une force de kassav ou
bien douce et quoi ccc vos croyances qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes aussi
rayonnante mais voilà c'est le destin
j'ai survécu et je dois profiter à fond
de tout ce qui m'arrive oui je pense
qu'il ya un peu de ça et mon caractère
naturel
cet accident m'a permis de me découvrir
vous c'est relativement voilà ce que ça
vous a donné plus de force oui
évidemment parce que aujourd'hui comme
tout le monde après j'ai des épreuves et
ça me permet pas de relativiser dois
dire que j'ai vu bien pire et je peux me
relever de dire ça alors juste c'était
votre premier vol en avion celui là
voilà plus en plus c'est au bout des
doigts c'était un cadeau qu'on vous avez
fait c'était une occasion particulière
ou sli pour un voyage ah oui on devait
se rendre à un mariage qui devait avoir
lieu dans notre famille avec ma mère
c'est l'occasion aussi de rencontrer ma
femme qui aux comores je suis originaire
des comores
j'avais jamais vu donc c'était pour ça
c'est tout et c'est à quoi alors
violemment dans ce crash physiquement il
n'avait pas beaucoup de pas beaucoup de
séquelles vous êtes vous êtes très peu
très peu abîmée finalement oui j'ai eu
quelques brûlures une fracture avec ça a
vécu chez les unes aux bassins et c'est
tout rien de bien grave
et dans la reconstruction psychologique
ça a mis combien de temps ça a été assez
rare quand on voir dès que tout va bien
mais ça met un peu de temps où c'était
pareil aussi miraculeux non mais alors
j'ai pas été suivi par un psychologue
c'était mon choix c'est mon père qui m'a
beaucoup accompagné en fait dans ma
reconstruction et je n'ai pas de durée
il y avait des moments où ça allait d'un
moment ça allait moins bien mais encore
aujourd'hui un des moments par rapport à
tout ça la perte de masse et à des hauts
et des bas donc mais je fais mieux c'est
sûr qu'on n'a pas de durée comment
s'appelle votre papa caciques assez
bakassi bon embrassons